you should have the distinct advantage
of having already some of this on the
board
I was about to draw almost just so it's
ready to go and do the addition wonders
however I actually thought it would be
worth like these are the kinds of things
which I know which I often forget that
sometimes people don't know so I'm going
to very quickly run you through how how
do I do the components like you should
be able to do these without too much
thought like these are common grabs okay
so let me begin with the three sine X
you can see on my arm on my set of axes
right I've got my 1 2 3 4 5 do you
remember how I chose that number Wi-Fi
yeah good so the range here is negative
3 to 3 the range here is negative 2 to 2
and I'm adding these things so if for
example the 3 and the 2 coincide I add
the meadow get 5 right or if the
negative 3 the nature coincide I'll add
them together and I'll get negative 5
right now as you will see I don't end up
using that entire range but I don't know
that from the beginning so therefore I
draw my graph with the expectation I
might need it so 3 sine X I'm gonna go
right up to the 3 that'll be my range
okay now you can see I've got my markers
for naught 180 degrees and 360 degrees
okay sine starts at the origin comes up
and down it goes down and up simple one
right so the way I do this visually I
don't tend to do too many markings
because it can start to cross over from
okay now it's informative versus now
it's just cluttered okay so I look about
halfway between there and there well
that'll give me 90 degrees and that's
where I'm gonna get that peak on my sine
curve right right there there's my
stationary point for sine I in the same
way I'm gonna have a stationary point
down here halfway between 180 and 360
and it's going to be in correspondingly
down here at negative three right so
I've got that point there okay no even a
pass three one two three four five
points that's all I need that's all I
need so I can draw my graph now up
down the station quick and efficient
okay you should be able to do that
roughly and quickly without any extra or
working or anything like that so there's
three sine X when I do 2 cos 2 X you
know two things number one amplitude has
changed it's no longer 3 it's - okay so
it's a little bit long and the other
thing that's changed is that it's a
period right the period is half as long
or if you wanna figure out the other way
the frequency is well it's twice as
frequent hypertension prefer thinking
about frequency because then you don't
have to reverse this number if I see too
close to X I know it's twice as frequent
or if it's 2 cos 3x it's three times as
frequently and so on so therefore
usually cosine goes down and then up and
that it finishes right but instead of
doing that in order to 360 that's the
regular period it's gonna do it from not
too funny
so now again I think about my stationary
points my endpoints right I'm gonna
start off here sorry that's three I'm
gonna start here at two
I'm gonna come down to the middle of the
graph which is going to be the middle of
this graph right from nought to 180 is
the whole period okay so therefore about
halfway down here there's the bottom of
the graph right so visualizing you're
coming down and it's going to do the
opposite coming up to 180 there you came
with that so there's my down that's one
complete cycle I just need to repeat it
that's all I need to do so you can see
over here it's going to be negative two
and it should finish up here at positive
two and then I just drive it up
but uh okay so here are my two wave
functions here the two things I'm gonna
add together okay
now think again when we're doing
addition and subtraction of ordinates
think about the easy places the easy
places okay so think about any routes
think about the routes right anytime you
get an x intercept
for example here you're gonna have 0
plus something as it happens is 2 so 0
plus 2 is 2
yeah as I move over right I'm gonna have
another 0 plus something else okay so
I'm gonna passing through there but
where else have I got a route well I see
what here at him I'm gonna another pair
dinner now I've done the first half the
graph I look at the second half the
Brits are here here and here there are 3
more to deal with right
this one is this posture negative number
so you gonna go down do you see that and
then I finished there
so I've dealt with all of the
x-intercepts of my component graphs does
that make sense
ok there are a couple other important
points that I can look at look at those
look at those on before I get to them
I'm gonna go look at the turning points
we're gonna turning points in my
component graphs then pretty important I
think okay they're not only important
but I happen to know cuz it's a tree
function I know exactly where they are
as well okay so for instance here I've
got three and it coincides in negative
two so when you add three and negative
two you you get one so I don't we take
me
then that make sense it exactly the same
way I've got another pair of snakes for
your points coinciding yeah so I've got
well let's have a look here this is
negative two
this is thank you three so when you add
them you get negative 5 all the way down
the bottom and you notice all the way
down the bottom because that's the
lowest that both graphs can get so you
put it together and that's the lowest
absolutely okay and then my last one is
okay way to the grass intercept cuz you
just take those points and then you
either double or you know you you do
don't worry okay actually start to take
that back it's my second busting so here
my two points of intersection right so
when you add these they should be double
behind that okay so it looks like I'm
getting a point here
okay that was the second last one the
very last one is not where they
intersect where they are the same
vertically upwards but where they are
opposites like vertically up and
vertically down a matching amount so
with a ruler again I would look at looks
to be somewhere like here right so for
instance those legs nip roughly
equivalent do they not and I can say
roughly because this whole argument is
visual so it does need to be precise
okay you can't actually find out it's
not hard to solve for when that is equal
we can do that later if you like
and correspondingly I've got another
point around here where maybe this
vertical and this vertical look about
the same so they're going to cancel
because one is positive ones negative
one is positive
what's they do so when you add them you
get zero okay so therefore I've got an
actual intercept there
okay hurrah now go through all the
points and look that's a lot of points
no anything else bothering this you can
just join the dots so let's do it
that's the sound you want to make one
okay once what do you think okay it's
weird isn't it is weird but that's okay
noting that both graphs are actually
going to repeat every 300 degrees I know
this one's going to repeat every 180 but
that just means he repeats twice every
360 degrees therefore if I draw it drew
this and kept going what happens is the
next thing I hear well it just does this
doesn't it
it's gonna do another another up back
down and then you're back yeah exactly
kind of double hook okay so that's not
that hard as you go logically through
think carefully about the ordinates and
how they're behaving okay